fighting in the aisle on arrival in
Crete last summer a pilot punched as he
tried to step in
this passenger on route to Lithuania was
so drunk and aggressive seven people had
to help restrain him
and this man on a flight to Turkey
became so intoxicated he decided to
strip off
you're up there at 38 000 feet with 300
passengers 16 crew and you have to deal
with the situation on your own it can
leave a very long lasting impact we're
all human at the end of the day this man
spent 20 years as cabin crew and twice
had to put drunken passengers in
restraints once after a man sexually
assaulted a woman and then tried to hide
in a Cellar cabinet the passenger was
intoxicated and had taken some sort of
medication we tried to calm him down but
the situation became aggressive and
uncontrollable a decision that we don't
take lightly was made to restrain him we
had to physically grab his arms and put
the cuffs on he was shouting and
swearing which was very offensive
the majority of passengers
well behaved but many crew have had to
deal with some serious incidents one air
Stuart I spoke to had recently been
punched in the face by a passenger he
told to stop smoking in 2019 UK Airlines
reported 373 incidents of intoxicated
violence or unruly passengers and while
the numbers fell during covid last year
there were 1028 cases triple the
pre-pandemic figure while it's thought
that's largely down to better reporting
the conservative MP Gareth Johnson says
the numbers are too high and the law
needs to change this bill aims to ensure
that violent people who cause Mayhem on
airplanes have actually banned from
flying for a specific period of time
from a court to add to that sort of
deterrent factor in addition to any
penalty they get the difficulty that we
have at the moment is that someone can
be violent on a particular operator's
airplane and in that operator cannot
pass that information onto another
operator so that person could just go
and fly with a different company watch
out the government say there's already
robust legislation in place including
Airline bans and fines of up to five
thousand pounds
if the numbers keep Rising the pressure
to do more will surely take off Amanda
raycast Sky News